you were worried about you know how
celebrities might react to you when you
walk out there on stage so you sent out
a tweet this morning to try and I think
to try and put everyone at ease is that
right
what was that when you sent out a
photograph it's a tweet of look at this
where that hopefully would that's you
you're trying to get them to feel
comfortable because this is you as a
child I know and in yours you're a
sweetie pie
yeah but everyone's sweet when they're
little all night I mean Hitler was
probably cute when he was that age
oh I don't you aren't the horrible and
then things happen well you know I've
never heard Hitler's career described as
things happen the new biopic that is
epic that we should do one but just to
do the mother always a doll other team
on his potty oh that's in painting
that's him being rejected from art
college that's him in the bunker blowing
his brains out
skipped over a lot there yeah yeah yeah
you say she said very short cuz it part
of this big chunk missing yeah yeah
birthday you ha ha welcome to denier
yeah oh you sent out a tweet that was
related to our own Andy Richter not too
long ago can we show that yeah yeah you
tweeted this photo oh yeah
I just that's right is the face that
Andy makes at me I think I'm through
your show sometime I hate the face you
make it during the show look at
[Applause]
good I love that see we were all cute
when we were over you hurry up just
proved a failure app let's take a quick
break much more with Ricky Gervais just
say